lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
tomar esta cantidad que está
representada por estas barras verdes en
las que cada barra representa uno y
tratar de representar esta cantidad
usando los dígitos que conocemos 0 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 y la manera de hacerlo es
agrupando las barras en grupos de 10 en
decenas quiero ver cuantas decenas tengo
y al mismo tiempo ver cuántas unidades
sobran cuántas barras quedan sin agrupar
así que tratemos de agrupar esto en
decenas aquí tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
hasta aquí tengo 10 una decena y la voy
a encerrar en un rectángulo este es un
grupo de 10 una decena y vamos a ver si
tenemos más grupos de 10 1 2 3 4 5 6
de 8 9 10 aquí tengo mi segundo grupo de
10 también lo voy a encerrar en un
rectángulo este es mi segundo grupo de
10 y parece que tengo varios grupos más
de 10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 aquí tengo
otro más este es mi tercer grupo de 10
mi tercera decena y parece que tengo una
decena más vamos al siguiente grupo de
10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 también voy a
encerrar en un rectángulo el cuarto
grupo de 10 barras que tengo aquí esta
es la cuarta decena que tengo entonces
aquí tengo una decena otra decena
aquí está la tercera decena y la cuarta
decena
podemos decir 10 10 10 10 o también
podemos decir que todo este conjunto es
igual a 4 1 2 3 4 decenas pero no ha
terminado con este número porque todavía
tengo dos barras de este lado una y dos
dos unidades que quedaron aquí
esta es una unidad
una unidad y esta otra
también es una unidad aquí tengo dos
unidades en total
recuerden que cada una de estas barras
verdes representan una unidad entonces
cuál es el número que está representado
en todo esto
bueno aquí tenemos cuatro decenas una
decena dos decenas tres decenas cuatro
decenas más dos unidades y voy a
escribirlo aquí abajo cuatro decenas más
dos unidades dos unidades pero qué es
esto qué significa esto bueno si usamos
el sistema numérico que estamos
acostumbrados a usar diríamos que
nuestro sistema numérico tiene una forma
de representar esto porque la primera
posición es la posición de las unidades
y lo voy a escribir en color azul esta
es la posición de las unidades y aquí
usamos uno de los dígitos 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 para saber cuántas unidades
tenemos y aquí escribimos 2
tenemos dos unidades y en la siguiente
posición a la izquierda es donde decimos
cuantas decenas tenemos esta es la
posición de las decenas y sabemos
cuántas decenas tenemos cuatro tenemos
cuatro decenas y la manera en que
representamos esto en nuestro sistema
numérico es cuatro decenas y dos
unidades a este número le llamamos 42 y
otra manera en que podemos pensar en
esto es cuatro decenas una decena dos
decenas tres decenas cuatro decenas es
igual a cuatro decenas que es lo mismo
que cuarenta y una vez más estamos
usando nuestro sistema numérico para
representar esto y luego tenemos dos
unidades y solo para recordarlo muy bien
este 4 representa 4 decenas que es lo
mismo que 40